during the four years of the trump
presidency millions of americans have
become followers of the right wing
conspiracy theory known as q
anon followers believed that a great
awakening in the u.s
and around the world was about to happen
they scoured anonymous
web postings from a shadowy q figure and
interpreted tweets and statements by
former u.s president donald trump as
messages sent from their champion they
expected some kind of epiphany to occur
on inauguration day
but there was no epiphany bidem became
president
trump left the white house and q anon
followers
are facing a harsh reality check
well my colleague ami and s if he has
been following this story for us
i mean remind us one of what exactly is
q anon and is there any way to know how
many people
are still followers well q anon is a
movement based on a conspiracy theory
that's based on trump so trump's
presidency was at the center of this
they believed that
he was going to save them from a cabal
of
satan worshiping pedophiles in the u.s
government
mostly among democrats and also
high-profile hollywood celebrities
they believe a lot of tropes that come
from old anti-semitic
conspiracy theories and they believe
that trump was going to save them
all from this now as in terms of how
many people actually follow this
movement that's really hard because it's
all online
or most of it's online anyway some
estimates by facebook and independent
estimates by
the guardian have put that number around
three million people who have accounts
that are associated
with q anon accounts and they're all
following this one person who posts
under the name of q so none of this is
based on evidence i have to say
that maybe for some people out there
listening in but
um it's based on just these anonymous
postings online so it's really hard to
tell how many people are active
but just in my travels across the us i
would say three million is
a huge underestimate because if you just
talk to
uh people at trump rallies they might
not say i am a follower of
anonymous but they say um they're doing
the right thing or i believe that
um there is this cabal of uh child
sex track traffickers and we know that a
key belief of cubanon followers is that
donald trump remains
u.s president right so obviously he's no
longer in power
what's going to happen then to the
movement well it's been a reckoning for
the movement inauguration day when joe
biden became the president of the united
states and trump had to
leave to florida that was an existential
crisis for the movement
now we were looking on chat rooms where
a lot of cue anonymous
q anon followers talk about
what to do next and you could see that
there was several main things you had
people
who were continuing to protest as we saw
there um who are just going on as if
nothing happened
there's people who um have left the the
movement who have said okay this was all
fake i've wasted my time
and there's you know there's also people
who have tried to incorporate biden's
presidency into a new narrative
and now what you have to for what you
can't forget is that trump is still
alive he's still out there so he can
still
play a role in um in organizing this
somehow at least being a symbolic
uh figure in this now we talked um to
uh the the um head of the podcast the
host of a podcast
q on people are basically faced with a
kind of double down or
back down position what what happens in
those cases historically
is more radicalization among the people
that remain
and more uh i suppose violent outbursts
but what's always been a risk with q
anon is the most mentally ill within the
system
they're like kernels of popcorn that go
off on the fringes of the movement
and they harm themselves and usually the
people that they love
around them their family structures
their friend structures and that's what
we're going to be seeing
very soon i believe because of the
cognitive dissonance created by
this great disappointment yeah kernels
of popcorn going off i mean we know that
germany is home to a
a fringe a major fringe of q anon
outside of the us what do we know about
that and what do we know about the role
of donald trump
in in this fringe that's a really good
question donald trump being the
former president of the u.s what does
that mean for the rest of the world now
like you said there germany is
considered to be the home of the largest
base of q anon followers
outside of the english-speaking world
there's telegram channels uh there's
online chat rooms where a lot of germans
are also communicating about this uh
false conspiracy theory and some people
have put the estimate around
150 000 followers of the movement within
germany which is pretty significant
now trump does play a major role in this
you'll see these
these trademark red maga hats at a lot
of
rallies here especially around the
pandemic because pandemic has been a big
issue for germans
a lot of conspiracy theorists not
believing that uh
kovid 19 exists and because trump early
on
had also cast doubt on how serious it
was they took that as a sign that he was
that he was going to do something for
them so you saw a lot of that playing
out here
and like i said it's going to continue
to play a role as long as trump is still
around and
making statements yeah and despite all
of the cognitive dissonance that she was
talking about
amin thank you